wohnungsnot und steigende mieten sind
ins zentrum der politischen debatte in
deutschland gerückt die rezepte reichen
von bauen bauen bauen bis hin zu
enteignungen unser heutiger studiogast
ist einer der größten und
erfolgreichsten immobilien unternehmer
in deutschland christoph gröner er ist
der gründer namensgeber und
vorstandsvorsitzende der cg gruppe
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix schönen
guten tag herr grüner die meisten
unternehmer die meisten reichen in
deutschland sind sehr
öffentlichkeitsscheu legen wert auf
diskretion bei ihnen ist es anders sie
gehen bewusst in die öffentlichkeit
gehen den talkshows kommen hier zu uns
in diese sendung warum die unternehmen
brauchen auch eine interessensvertretung
es kann ja nicht sein dass wir alle
politischen farben täglich im fernsehen
sehen dass wir institutionen sehen dass
wir verbände sehen aber die um die es
geht in deutschland der mittelstand sich
scheuen in der öffentlichkeit zu gehen
insofern gehe ich mit freude unsere
sache vertreten hier in solche sendungen
und hoffe dass ich einen beitrag leisten
kann dass die öffentlichkeit sich selber
eine meinung bilden kann die über alle
köpfe hinweg und welche reaktionen
erhalten sie darauf dass sie sich so
offen zu reichtum macht und erfolg
bekennen
das ist ein kapitel des etwas schwerer
zu besprechen ist das reicht von
schwerwiegenden bedrohungen bis zu
liebesbekenntnisse ich will es mal so
sagen in den letzten monaten hat sich
das entschärft wir haben zuspruch wir
haben kritik wir haben die möglichkeit
im unternehmen die reflektion darauf zu
machen also auf das was ich hier sagen
weil das wird ja so ein bisschen auch
als ja als strategie eines unternehmens
gefahren dass wir sagen der grüner kann
der und darf der soweit er geht in die
öffentlichkeit weil es geht ja dann auch
später um die belange meine mitarbeiter
meiner angestellten die ja letztendlich
auch davon betroffen sind bis hin in
meiner familie die letztes jahr da doch
in mitleidenschaft gezogen wurde weil
schwerwiegend
bedrohungslage entstanden ist die
mithilfe von verfassungsschutz und bka
werden wir nachher gleich darüber
aufgelöst werden konnte aber ich habe
von überall die unterstützung aus der
familie ich habe die unterstützung aus
dem unternehmen alle sind der auffassung
wir sollen für das was wir hier ein
stehen auch öffentlich werden und das
ist der grund viele zuschauer kennen sie
vielleicht aus der ard-dokumentation
ungleich land hat ein kamerateam see ein
halbes jahr lang begleitung das schauen
wir uns zunächst einmal kurz und schnell
danken
kurz vor acht uhr am morgen in berlin
der fahrer wartet schon
er weiß dass es schnell gehen muss wenn
der chef kommt christoph gröner sohn
eines lehrers hat sich hochgearbeitet
schuftet nicht selten 20 stunden am tag
er ist das was man einen leistungsträger
nennt
fahre gerne und passionierte autofahrer
aber die frage ist wofür bezahlt nicht
mein unternehmen das sich am lenkrad
sitzen oder dafür dass ich arbeite
grüner verdient sein geld mit immobilien
kaum eine firma in deutschland baut so
viel wie seine und auf dem wohnungsmarkt
kennen die preise nur eine richtung
steil nach oben
gerade hat seine firma ein ganz
besonderes haus gekauft
der steglitzer kreisel soll einmal der
höchste wohnturm der stadt werden
christoph gröner sucht immer die
herausforderung
er will in weniger als fünf minuten bis
ganz nach oben laufen
ein wettkampf gegen sich selbst 30
etagen 120 meter 600 stufen ein
mitarbeiter stoppt die zeit
[Musik]
eigentlich was für die schaffen
ja ich kann mich noch erinnern wie ich
aus den augenwinkeln zu zeiten des
abiturs boris becker beim wimbledon sich
beobachtet habe und dass ich gedacht
habe sagte nur ich ziehe noch gleich
zwischen 5.000 und 10.000 euro wird man
hier für einen quadratmeter wohnung
zahlen müssen
von hier oben blickt grüne auf viele
seiner bauprojekte eigentlich spur die
letzten 20 jahre hier in berlin
verfolgen
fast 4000 wohnungen weitere 3000 dem bau
wir haben hier mitgewirkt im wohnungsbau
sag ich mal ist das wirklich das was
hier antreibt ich will so erfolgreich
sein wie boris becker sicher nicht was
mich antreibt ist sind visionen
ich möchte ein unternehmen gestalten ich
möchte ein unternehmen in die welt
setzen dessen daseinsberechtigung hat
dieses unternehmen wird auch in zukunft
wohnungen zwischen 5 und 10 tausend euro
in quadratmetern bauen aber es wird auch
ganz sicher in den bezahlbaren wohnraum
wohnungen errichten wie so weil die
zukunft in deutschland ist eben nicht
der porsche oder ein teures fahrzeug
sondern die zukunft ist der golf und der
vg und das kann man in die
immobilienbranche übertragen
wir haben eine bevölkerung 85 prozent
der bevölkerung kann sich wohnraum von 8
19 euro und quadratmeter leisten die
anderen 15 prozent sind in den letzten
jahren von allen möglichen entwicklern
bedient worden haben hochpreisige
wohnungen bekommen haben sie auch
zurecht gekauft benutzen sie mieten sie
aber wir haben ihm eine bevölkerung die
dringend darauf wartet bezahlbaren
wohnraum zu bekommen meine vision ist
dass ich mit dem unternehmensgruppe eben
den bezahlbaren wohnraum hinbekommen
dazu müssen wir den prozess ändern dazu
müssen wir die machart eine mobile
ändern heißt wir müssen building
information modeling wir müssen private
cajun für den zuschauer heißt das wir
müssen also vorgefertigte teile auf die
baustelle
bringen wir müssen das human capital
runter fahren wenn es mit weniger
menschen das bauwerk errichten können
vorgefertigte auf der baustelle
wetterunabhängig und damit werden wir es
schaffen den bezahlbaren wohnraum eben
für zehn euro mieten quadratmeter in
deutschland zu etablieren
das treibt mich an so ein ziel zu
erreichen mich treibt fahne an als
unternehmer in den städten in denen wir
wirken auch für kinder für charity
einzutreten um die spur zu hinterlassen
das wirtschaft kinder kann das sind die
beiden großen fundamente die mich stark
machen das unternehmen der weise zu
lesen sind gleich darüber reden ob und
wie man in deutschland bezahlbaren
wohnraum schaffen trotzdem vielleicht
noch ein paar sätze zu dem wie alles
angefangen hat
die meisten reichen in deutschland sind
reich weil sie reich geerbt haben willst
du bei ihnen wie haben sie angefangen
also ich habe sicher reich an
erfahrungen angefangen ich habe sicher
mit allen möglichen reichtümer
angefangen aber geld hatte ich keins ich
habe vor 30 jahren mit einem kleinen
unternehmen ein einzelunternehmen
begonnen des christoph grüner baum
hilfsdienste da habe ich abbrucharbeiten
vollführte habe ich bei hilfsdiensten
vorgeführt da habe ich alles mögliche
auf eine branche selber gemacht und
deshalb macht mir diesen händen mit
diesem kreuz das heute noch kaputt ist
ich habe also über zehn jahre auf der
baustelle mitgewirkt als helfer als
später auch fachkraft ich habe dann ein
bauunternehmen aus dem christen corinna
belz dienst gemacht das heißt ich habe
mit null angefangen
ich habe höhen und tiefen gehabt ich bin
natürlich wie so ein unternehmen auch
beginnt gescheitert ich bin dann wieder
aufgestanden ich bin dann wieder
gescheitert dann wieder aufgestanden
erfolg da zu sein wo ich heute bin hat
er damit zu tun dass ich schneller auf
stehe dass sie vielleicht mutiger bin an
der einen oder anderen stelle und
vielleicht als erster in der stadt
berlin im jahr 2008 war vielleicht als
erster in offenbach in 2002 als erster
die richtigen mainstreams gefunden hat
oder die potenziale verstanden hat aber
hat mit irgendwelchem reichtum aus dem
elternhaus nichts zu tun mein vater war
beamter meine mutter ist lehrerin
da war also bestimmt kein startkapital
für eine unternehmerische karriere da
kann man trotzdem noch mal zum zum
erfolg sind sie erfolgreich weil sie so
ein riecher haben oder weil sie härter
arbeiten oder war da einfach auch viel
glück dabei sind die kombination aus
allem also
ich bezeichne das immer so sie müssen
immer an diesen stationen wurde erfolg
vorbei fährt auch stehen sie müssen früh
aufstehen zu müssen immer dabei sein
müssen zielstrebig sein
sie müssen wenn sie gefallen sind wieder
aufstehen und die kombination aus
sicherlich fleiß hartnäckigkeit auch aus
einer guten idee
anders als alle anderen sie müssen etwas
entwickeln was andere nicht entwickeln
dann brauchen sie ganz sicher noch eine
große portion glück ohne das geht es
nicht aber die kombination aus einem
machtmenschen erfolgreich und ich würde
mit dem wort erfolgreich vorsichtig
umgehen erfolgreich würde ich mich dann
bezeichnet wenn es mir gelungen weil ist
meine vision umzusetzen wenn es mir
gelungen ist tatsächlich den bezahlbaren
wohnraum zu schaffen tatsächlich auch
ein footprint für die kinder in den
städten in denen wir sind zu
hinterlassen
da würde ich mich dann erstmals
erfolgreich bezeichnen heute bin ich auf
dem weg ein erfolgreicher mensch dass
ein und arbeitet dafür hat jetzt ist ja
die immobilienbranche sehr volatil
möchte ich mal sagen je nachdem wie die
konjunktur läuft die eingehend leute die
anderen verdienen sehr viel geld wie sie
es denn bei ihnen verdienen sie viel
geld oder müssen sie jeden morgen
aufstehen und sagen hoffentlich überlebt
mein unternehmen wir haben keine
existenzängste weil in diesem
immobilienmarkt zur zeit tätig ist und
ein bisschen sachverstand hat verdient
automatisch geld die frage ist bin ich
stehe ich morgens auf um geld zu
verdienen und da stehe ich morgens auf
um ein ziel zu verfolgen wir investieren
enorm
in eben die neuen technologien will
investieren enorm in fabriken die in
zukunft verfolgt fertige teile
produzieren wir investieren enorm in den
bezahlbaren wohnraum ich möchte für
meine angestellten und führt das land in
dem ich arbeite
etwas hinterlassen was bezahlbaren
wohnraum bedeutet das bedeutet wir
stehen nicht auf um jetzt die nächsten
paar jahre immobilien halb noch
mitzunehmen um die kassen voll zu machen
und dann abzuwarten bis der nächste hype
hinterher kommt sondern wir stehen
tatsächlich da und sagen wir wollen den
vw der mobilen branche schaffen wir
wollen bezahlbaren wohnraum für die
bürger und bürgerinnen in deutschland
schaffen und das thema der reden wir
drüber ich würde trotzdem 1 gerne noch
wissen sie haben dieses erfolgreiche
immobilienunternehmen wie wie viel
vermögen haben sie denn mein vermögen
spielt dabei keine rolle weil mein von
mir mich interessiert sich hat mal
gelesen 80 millionen
müssen wir jetzt nicht was weiß ich ihre
finanzen offenlegen aber mich wird
interessieren drunter oder drüber 80
millionen stimmt das die frage ist
insofern prekär sagen wir es mal so weil
sie von vielen dingen abhängt lassen sie
einfach mal offen darüber sprechen daher
grüner hat immobilien über die jahre
gesammelt
manchmal unfreiwillig weil die häuser
sie nicht verkauften von 10 20 jahren
ist also zu immobilien gekommen diese
immobilien sind berlin
jetzt wollen wir beide mal herausfinden
wie hoch ist mein vermögen aus den
immobilien bereich bei welcher preis
gilt der der heute gerade mal weil der
immobilien halb hoch ist oder der der
vielleicht morgen da sind weil die
immobilien in berlin
das heißt sie können in dem bereich bei
einem immobilienbestand von mir aus von
100 millionen jetzt mit mir vorzüglich
darüber treffen wenn der morgen nur noch
50 wert ist dann habe ich kein vermögen
aus immobilien wenn er morgen bei 100
ist habe ich vielleicht 50 oder 60
millionen das gleiche ist mit meiner
aktien
ich habe aktien von der c gruppe ich
habe aber auch bürgschaften mit 70
gruppe als unternehmer gegeben ich habe
über 80 millionen bürgschaften bank
gegeben womit ich versichere dass mein
geschäftskonzept aufgeht und ich mich
persönlich dahinter stellen
jetzt können sie meine aktien mit 50 mit
100 oder 200 millionen bewerten jetzt
können wir beide vorträge vorzüglich
darüber diskutieren bin ich jetzt 50
millionen schwer 0 unter -
millionenschwere das heißt wir sind
damit sagen möchte
bei einem unternehmer der es ernst meint
gibt es vermögen die vermögen sind
sicherlich auch in irgendeiner art und
weise bewertbar und sicherlich ist eine
größenordnung von 0 bis 300 millionen
eine zahl in der sich irgendwie das
abbilden ist aber entscheiden wir es
doch nicht welches vermögen ich habe
sondern was passiert mit dem vermögen
mit dem vermögen mit dem modernes der
fertigteile das modernste fertigteil
berg der welt gerade gebaut in erfurt
dafür habe ich mein privates vermögen
geben mit dem vermögen werden
restaurants betrieben hostels betrieben
und das ist auch die machart und das was
ich ihnen auch entgegen möchte der
mittelstand in deutschland ist jemand
der nicht irgendwo vermögen hortet oder
irgendwo ein konto eröffnet und geld
einsammeln sondern reinvestiert ich kann
ihnen sagen mein kontostand heute morgen
war bei null ich hab's gestern schon
gesagt dann sind wir mitleidsbekundungen
nein weil ich heute morgen das letzte
geld dafür ausgegeben habe wieder eine
etwas zu erwerben wieder mich irgendwo
zu investieren und morgen ist natürlich
wieder geld auf dem konto
aber unabhängig davon geht es darum was
macht in deutschland der mittelstand was
macht der christoph gröner mit seinem
vermögen ag investiert ist er sorgt für
arbeitsplätze alleine in meinem bereich
also nicht in meiner unternehmung cd
kowacki in der grünen gruppe sind heute
über 50 menschen beschäftigt mit der
aussicht dass er mehrere hundert
menschen auch in dem bereich beschäftigt
sein werden ja okay da haben jetzt
ungefähr so eine idee bekommen wie sie
da denken und welche summen sie da
investieren dann reden wir jetzt mal
über das thema dieser tage über die
wohnungsnot
warum gibt es wohnungsnot und zumindest
in einigen großstädten explodierende
mieten in deutschland wir haben mehrere
über sich überschlagenden entwicklungen
die eine entwicklung ist dass die bundes
deutschland aufgehört hat zb
sozialwohnungen zu bauen wir hatten noch
vor zehn jahren bestand vor 15 jahren
bestand von drei millionen
sozialwohnungen heute ist ins 1,2
millionen
dazu haben die kommunen wie dresden wie
berlin ihre wohnungsbestände komplett
abgebaut verkauft weil sie geld in der
kasse haben wollten das ist die eine
geschichte also die kommunen sind ihrer
verantwortung nicht nachgekommen gehen
sie nach mannheim die haben es geschafft
gehen sie nach wien die haben's
geschafft die haben investiert die
letzten 20 jahre also gemeinden und
kommunen die in den letzten 20 jahren
nicht dem mammon sozusagen hinterher
gelaufen sind und schnell mal das
tafelsilber verscherbelt haben sondern
zielgerichtet ihre politik
wohnungspolitik betrieben haben und
immer wussten was jeder heute weiß sie
brauchen für fünf bis zehn prozent der
bevölkerung wohnung die aus den
staatlichen ressourcen kommt wieso bei
fünf bis zehn prozent der bevölkerung
niemals sich am markt eine wohnung
eindecken kann bezahlen kann dh rentner
sozialhilfeempfänger jemand der eben
förderung in anspruch nehmen muss wird
auf dem normalen mietmarkt keine wohnung
bekommen da muss der staat für sorgen
und es ist richtig und wichtig das macht
deswegen haben wir ein operatives
bauland modell für den zuschauer heißt
es wir bauen wohnung und verpflichten
uns sozialwohnung zu bauen ohne
zuschüsse
das findet in ganz deutschland statt
aber die zweite über lagen der
geschichte ist dass wir heute etwas über
82 millionen menschen haben die in
deutschland leben
die statistiken und alles das was es die
letzten 20 jahre gegeben haben sind von
79 millionen menschen ausgegangen und es
mal ganz frech gesagt die alten sterben
und die mütter haben plötzlich
angefangen kinder zu kriegen und die
europäer haben
deutschland für sich entdeckt und sind
nach deutschland gezogen wir reden hier
nicht von der referees wir reden einfach
nur von den griechen von dem spanier von
dem franzosen von dem italiener von dem
letten die einfach entdeckt haben hier
gibt es arbeitsplätze ich möchte hier
daher haben wir drei millionen mehr
menschen als noch vor zehn 15 jahren
prognostiziert
warum werden die dadurch notwendigen
wohnungen nicht gebraucht jetzt die
wohnungen gibt es im prinzip weil die
bundes deutschland hat 82 millionen
menschen und 41 millionen haushalte das
heißt wir haben mehr wohnungen als jede
andere europäische jedes andere
europäische land und wer mehr wohnfläche
pro kopf wie jedes andere europäische
land und wir haben nirgends günstigere
ziel mieten als in deutschland das muss
man mal wissen also je einkommen das
heißt wenn wir darüber sprechen dass in
berlin sich der wohnraum verdreifacht
hat den kosten deswegen weil wir auf
allen unendlich niederen niveau begonnen
haben und heute auf einem vernünftigen
niveau sind wir müssen ein bisschen die
kirche im dorf lassen
darüber sprechen wir haben eigentlich
super verhältnisse in deutschland was
wohnen betrifft jetzt kommt s 2 neben
der entwicklung dass wir viel mehr
menschen haben die in deutschland heute
noch leben und eben sich ja auch auf
halten als es berechnet war haben wir
noch die entwicklung dass wir einen in
der ganzen welt typisches verhalten
haben dass alle versuchen in die
innenstädte zu kommen alle möchten in
die großen städte ziehen und diese
entwicklung führt dazu dass ein paar
hunderttausend menschen in den letzten
jahren nach berlin ziehen wollten oder
man nicht genug wohnraum geschaffen
wurden ein paar hunderttausend menschen
frankfurt/köln usw sozusagen in die
zentren der großen städte wollen wir
sprechen also nicht darüber dass
irgendjemand aus berlin verdrängt wird
wir sprechen darüber dass welche nicht
reinkommen aber da muss ich jetzt an der
stelle ein haken sie sagen die städte
sind schuld die die umstände und die
verhältnisse sind da schon da ist das
sicher sehr sehr vieles dran an dem was
sie sagen
trotzdem gibt es ja sehr viele menschen
die sagen wohnbauunternehmen
immobilienunternehmen wie ihre
verschärfen die situation noch weil sie
eben luxuswohnungen bauen weil sie eben
am profit orientiert sind und am ende
werden eben doch auch durch die
steigenden mieten personen menschen aus
berlin verdrängt oder aus münchen oder
aus stuttgart also wir haben soziale
marktwirtschaft und da steckt auch das
wort marktwirtschaft noch drin und wir
können nicht bestreiten dass eine
entwicklung
in berlin langfristig dazu führen wird
dass die innenstadt auch menschen
vertragen werden muss die ein höheres
einkommen haben das heißt wir werden
einige infizierung haben die nicht heißt
dass jemand verdrängt wird aber dass
welche dazukommen die gutes geld
verdient man sollte dem verdrängt werden
wenn die drei neuen in berlin ständig
steigen in münchen ständig steigen
natürliche stärken werden leute
verdrängt weil sie sich eine neue
wohnung nach der steuerungs wechselt er
macht mir leid aber nicht durch die
wohnung die ich baue
lasst uns doch mal den münchnern nach
berlin ziehen der münchner dann nach
berlin zieht und eine arbeitsstelle hat
er hat ein richtig gutes einkommen
sollte er jetzt hinter dem mieter der in
berlin schon lebt stehen und sobald er
aussieht dem seine wohnung höhere miete
nehmerländer neubau von herrn brüner
einsehen
ich plädiere also einen neubau von herrn
brüner ein sinn weil ich mit meinem
wohnraum quasi die mieter die von
außerhalb kommen absorbiere und den
druck wegnehmen von dem mietmarkt der
sich sage ich mal in berlin sonst
abzeichnet das heißt der generalverdacht
dass durch teure wohnung irgendetwas
sich insgesamt verteuert kann sie
ausschließlich auf das steigen des
mietspiegels projizieren wir haben aber
in berlin durchschnittsmieten von 56
euro wir sind also auf einem niveau das
ist absolut in ordnung ist für eine
hauptstadt wir haben ein anderes problem
in berlin
wir haben zu niedrige einkommen wir
haben viel zu viele menschen die
förderung in anspruch nehmen müssen wir
haben viel zu wenig leistungsfähiger
bürger die sich eine teure wohnung
leisten können die aber auch im edeka
einkaufen gehen oder die auch den
friseursalon und die kneipe rechts und
links von ihrer wohnung auch mit ihrem
geld auch sozusagen aufrechterhalten das
heißt wir brauchen kaufkraft in dieser
stadt durch verschiedene dinge zum
beispiel durch die ansiedlung von einer
ordentlichen produktion von ordentlichen
wirtschafts und industriebetriebe
da hat berlin versäumt und ich will es
trotzdem nicht negieren natürlich hat
die immobilienwirtschaft jetzt mal das
mitgenommen was wir mitnehmen konnte
aber das ist doch kein schaden wenn doch
die käufer von teuren wohnungen da sind
haben sie doch niemanden was weggenommen
wenn sie neu entstanden
jeder zuschauer wer wie kriegen das mit
sie sind ein an streitbare unternehmer
der für seine sache offensiv eintreten
und das ist sage ich mir auch gut so
dass sie ihre position vertreten sie
machen das auch den berliner senat
gegenüber sie haben an einer ihrer
baustelle schon auch mal ein banner
aufgehängt hier verhindert rot-rot-grün
den bau von wohnungen
sie bauen ihre wohnungen auch da wo es
wehtut zum beispiel haben sie ein
bauprojekt in der rigaer straße für hier
in berlin für alle die das nicht kennen
die rigaer straße ist so was wie das
zentrum der hausbesetzerszene
wir haben da auch noch eine kleine szene
die wir uns jetzt anschauen christoph
gröner und der erfolglose versuch mit
den hausbesitzern in dialog zu treten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist das jetzt mut oder hochmut dass sie
da so in den kind stehen auf ihrer
baustelle
leider ist es eine sehr verkürzte
darstellung die szene geht ungefähr zwei
stunden
und jetzt haben sie zwei minuten gezeigt
in den zwei stunden und die
veranstaltung war da was dazu sagen die
nachbarn und die menschen die in der
straße wohnen davon zu informieren was
wir da bauen wir bauen der wohnungen die
werden zwischen 8 und 14 euro vermietet
also keine luxussanierung wir bauen an
einer stelle in der vorher nichts war
wir haben niemand verdrängt keinen
einzigen meter heraus gedrängt sondern
wir haben eine große baulücke haben wir
bebaut oder bauen wir bis heute
und jetzt hat sich quasi der volkszorn
der übrigens herangekarrt ist keiner der
leute die dort im hof war und in der
umgebung keiner war der angesprochen
sind daher gebracht worden
aus dem linken block aus dem bereich die
eben ganz wenig interesse an dem
gespräch haben und ich habe mehrfach
darum gebeten dass vertreter der
menschen die da unten standen auf die
bühne kommt wir hatten vier fünf
mikrofone bereitet das glas und das
projekt diskutieren
lasst uns reingehen lassen uns die
mietpreise ansehen lassen schauen wo die
soziale aspekte von diesem projekt sind
lasst uns kritik von euch üben damit wir
lernen aus der kritik
es wurde nur zwei stunden geschrieben
und ich kann zurückschreiben ich werde
ich zurück sein und ich werde mir aber
von niemandem gar nichts reden lassen
und wir sind
ich kann der freie meinung äußern die
können schreien und ich kann ich sie
fragen ob sie blöd genug sind dass sie
glauben dass ein investor wie ich sich
durch geschrei abhalten lässt sie sind
wie sie sind und deshalb hoch muss
betonen okay also sie sind streit war
sie sind streitbar und weil sie so
streitbar sind und weil die hausbesetzer
szene so ist wie sie ist
sind sie zum feindbild der linken
geworden nicht der linken sondern weil
dieser dieser autonome szene geworden
das ist nicht ganz ungefährlich für sie
das haben wir schon darüber gesprochen
auf ihre privatwohnung in köln ist zum
beispiel ein anschlag verübt worden da
sind die scheiben eingeworfen worden
haben sie denn keine sorge wenn du wenn
schon nicht um sich selbst um ihre frau
um ihre vier kinder man gut meine vier
kinder sind geschützt das kann ich sagen
oder sie wohnen überhaupt nicht hier in
der umgebung oder sind überhaupt nicht
sozusagen greifbar und gelaufen internat
oder erlagen im ausland ja die sind im
ausland insofern geht so mich und auf
mich kann ich leider keine rücksicht
nehmen haben sie personenschutz
gelegentlich also die größte
abwehrtaktik ist ich bin jeden tag
woanders ich bin ständig unterwegs
ich arbeite tag und nacht und wer mich
an treffen möchte muss ganz schön
schnell sein
das ist übrigens das picasso sachen sie
angeblich keine wege das wiederholen
ich bin ich immer im gleichen ort ich
bin nahezu ich bin morgen den usa ich
bin ein paar wochen später in london ich
bin in gang zu das was wir tun dieses
creation dieses digitalisierung des
bauprozesses bedeutet ja dass ich mir
die impuls wochen außerhalb holen muss
dass ich mir die technologien von
außerhalb holen muss ich kann ja nicht
hingehen und sagen ich mache spitzbart
bezahlbare wohnen plötzlich und das
bedeutet dass ich sehr viel unterwegs
bin
wir haben zehn standorten in deutschland
ich bin nahezu jede woche in jedem
standort
insofern das eine ist die
unwahrscheinlichkeit und dass mich
jemand an trifft das andere ist ja ich
kann mich auch ganz gut werden
es gibt eine enteignungs debatte in
deutschland hier in berlin läuft ein
volksbegehren zur enteignung von großen
wohnungs immobilienunternehmen kevin
kühnert hat sogar angeregt dass
sämtliche private wohnungsvermieter
enteignet werden sollten ich vermute mal
das wird nicht so auf ihre zustimmung
stoßen also uns bisher schon nicht
treffen
wir sind ja ein unternehmen dass
wohnungen baut und dieser groll den wir
auf der straße leben und die
dahinterstehende abstimmung und
fragestellungen der enteignung ist ja
keine reelle debatte wir wissen dass das
enteignungen in deutschland nicht geben
wird wie paragraf für artikel 15
enteignungen in deutschland sind zum
zwecke der vergesellschaftung möglich
und es gibt genauso den paragrafen
daneben das eigentum garantiert insofern
enteignungen wären theoretisch möglich
aber wozu wenn also der staat wohnung
wie in berlin zum beispiel von einer
weile für 700 euro und kommt
er verkauft hat an die mono via oder die
deutsche wohnen und sie jetzt für 4000
euro in quadratmeter wieder zurückkauft
dann finde ich das eine lustige der
sozialistisch geführte debatte sie
sinnlos sie bringt nichts weil keine
neue wohnung entsteht das entscheidende
ist doch dass die wohnung die enteignet
werden nicht von sozialhilfeempfängern
nicht von armen leuten durchweg gemietet
werden sondern sind rechtsanwälte ärzte
und so weiter drin
also wir müssen ein ganz kleines
bisschen auf dem boden bleiben
in deutschland haben wir erst mal nur
noch 1,2 millionen sozialwohnungen lasst
uns wirklich ein programm auflegen wie
wir ganz schnell 34 5 millionen
wohnungen wieder zurückgewinnen in die
hände von kommunen und das schaffen wir
durch neubau in den nächsten fünf bis
zehn jahren ganz sicher wenn wir uns
anstrengen durch enteignung werden sie
dadurch nichts verbessern das zweite ist
wenn sie einmal nur mit der ersten
enteignung anfangen dann ist es vorbei
mit dem bau der freien wirtschaft sie
müssen sich mal vorstellen
die bundes deutschland die ländern
kommunen investieren ungefähr 2
milliarden im jahr in wohnung die freie
wirtschaft 200 milliarden
wie wollen sie das denn anstellen dass
plötzlich die länder und kommunen anfang
die herolds aufgabe der freien
wirtschaft zu übernehmen für 200
milliarden immobilien im jahr hin zu
stellen das können doch nur präsidenten
von tennisclubs bild kühnert verlangen
oder menschen die ganz weit aus der
realität interesse sind und noch nie
selber gearbeitet haben und da möchte
ich darauf gehen wer in einem betrieb
mal fünf oder zehn jahre gearbeitet hat
ein kontakt zu seinem chef hatte der
verstanden hatten die unternehmen
funktioniert wird niemals auf die idee
kommt eine solche forderung zu stellen
wir reden von sozialer marktwirtschaft
und in einer sozialen marktwirtschaft
müssen wir für ausgleich sorgen
ganz sicher aber die drei genossen wir
defizite und deren eigenes debatte in
deutschland bekommt unter anderem
deswegen so viel feuer weil die vermögen
in deutschland so ungleich verteilt sind
wie in kaum einem anderen land in europa
deswegen die frage ist das fair aus
ihrer sicht das sehen vermögen haben von
zig millionen wir haben jetzt darüber
diskutiert wie volatil das ist aber sie
haben die macht der das zu benutzen
dieses vermögen ist das fair und gerecht
und andere haben
also die erste frage ist was wir denn
passieren wir das vermögen andere haben
werden die 50 arbeitsplätze entstehen
würde das modernste fertigteilwerke der
welt entstehen würden wir innovative
szenarien für die zukunft bilden können
ist die erste frage die zweite frage ja
wenn die vermögen ungleich verteilt sind
oder ungerecht verteilt sind glauben sie
wirklich dass sie durch umverteilung zu
diesem zeitpunkt irgendwas verbessern
können jede und auf umverteilung
bedeutet eine dramatische
verschlechterung der situation für alle
eine dramatische alleine die erhebung
einer vermögenssteuer hat in frankreich
zum wegfall von 10.000 arbeitsplätzen zu
10.000 millionen investitionen geführt
und wie die vermögenssteuer wieder
abgeschafft wurde ist die
arbeitslosigkeit gesunken der
wirtschaftskraft des gestiegen und so
weiter was ich sagen möchte ist wenn wir
eine solche debatte führen lassen sich
auch über die zukunft sprechen lassen
sie uns ab morgen doch die vermögen
besser verteilen lassen und auch
mechanismen entwickeln wie wir ganz
viele menschen in deutschland in den
immobilienbesitz kommen wir haben 46
prozent die quote immobilienquote das
heißt menschen die die mobile besitzen
im europäischen ausland es gibt 70 80
prozent quote wo menschen immobilie wir
sie zu lassen und so ein programm
auflegen wie wir wirklich ganz viele
menschen noch dazu bringen dass sich
eine immobilie leisten können dazu
können wir alle möglichen szenarien
machen die gründerwerkstatt für privat
genutzte immobilien senken wir können
die umsatzsteuer auf 7 prozent senken in
privat genutzte immobilien wir können
spekulations steuern erheben für
grundstücke die brach liegen wohl nur
spekulationen da ist das können wir
alles machen wir können aber aus meiner
sicht auf keinen fall hingehen und da wo
schon vermögen verteilt sind darauf
zugreifen weil sich die leute die diese
vermögen geschaffen im größere klein in
aller regel sehr anständig diese
vermögen erarbeitet haben und
erwirtschaftet haben und ich sehe nicht
ein wieso ich in meinem verhalten
dadurch eine restriktion oder hinterher
auch noch bestraft werden soll
wenn ich jetzt 30 jahre tag und nacht
gearbeitet haben dann kommt irgendwie
meine reha nimmt mir das vermögen wert
und tut in afghanistan investieren oder
baut noch ein br mehr oder noch nie viel
harmonie hamburg mehr
ich nehme ihnen das ab dass sie wirklich
sehr sehr hart arbeiten
wir haben das ja im lauf dieser sendung
auch erfahren dass sie dadurch dass sie
so streitbar sind wirklich eine
persönliche gefährdungslage
gekommen sind ich würde mal
interessieren wie sie selbst persönlich
bilanz ziehen
lohnt sich das das wirklich also sie
verdient sehr viel geld sie haben sehr
viel erfolg und macht auf der anderen
seite haben sie vermutlich unterstelle
ich mal ihre ihre kinder gar nicht
richtig aufwachsen sehen weil die eben
im internat sind weil sie so viel
arbeiten stimmt ihre persönliche bilanz
also wenn sie ihre kinder unter der
woche im internat haben und sie haben
das ganze wochenende zeit sich ganz
intensiv mit ihren kindern zu
beschäftigen dann bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob der familienvater der jeden
abend übermüdet nach hause kommt und
sich nicht um seine kinder kümmert mehr
von seinen kindern hat als ich es hatte
ich habe sehr viel von meinen kindern
gehabt ich hoffe meine kinder können das
gleiche sagen ich glaube nicht dass ich
da defizit hatte und ich habe knallhart
vier fünf mal im jahr eine woche oder
zwei wochen auszeit genommen ich habe
dann die nacht gearbeitet als
unternehmer ist das normal
tagsüber die kinder nachts arbeiten im
urlaub das gehört einfach dazu
aber da würde ich mir jetzt in der
bilanz nichts ab sparen wollen oder mich
nicht schlechter rechnen wollen
es geht um ganz was anderes ich bin noch
nie morgens wegen geld auf gestand ich
bin noch nie wegen vermögen aufgestanden
noch nie war meine motivation
irgendetwas zu verdienen meine
motivation war immer einen betrieb
vorzustehen der etwas schafft innovativ
ist das treibt mich an
und wenn sie wie ich vor 30 jahren als
bauhelfer begonnen haben und heute darf
ich mit kommunen darf ich mit
bürgermeistern mit ministern über
quartiersentwicklung darf ich über große
areale diskutieren wie wir die
bedürfnisse der bevölkerung dort
abbilden von hotelbiz bürobau wohnung
des sozialen wohnungsbau bis geförderten
wohnraum und so weiter dann habe ich
eines der schönsten leben führen dürfen
bis heute dass ein mensch führen darf
das war völlig persönlich heute mit
christoph gröner herzlichen dankeschön